squad members who called for cancelling
rent during the pandemic reportedly
raked in thousands as landlords last
year financial disclosures show rashida
talib made 50 grand
while fellow squad member ayanna presley
collected as much as 15 000
both backed a bill that would have
temporarily canceled rent and mortgage
payments nationwide
dana is this hip
but critical if they include themselves
in this or should they have told us this
and
well they have to tell you because they
have financial disclosures right and
like most people don't necessarily have
to do that but if you're in public
office you do so that's why but i do
think it's i mean it's kind of hilarious
but it's also really upsetting so these
were the biggest proponents of the
eviction moratorium and yet they didn't
even cancel rent for their own tenants
yes that's the key if they hadn't
canceled i mean that's what i was
wondering did they cancel it and they
abide by their own rules no no and no
and the thing is that the urban
institute basically says that it is uh
black and hispanic small landlords that
are far more likely to be hurt by the
eviction moratorium here's three reasons
why they're more likely to have lower
income they usually only have one
property
and then they have to rely on that rent
collection to pay their own mortgage so
that's why this whole thing that
president biden did in which he said i
know it's unconstitutional but i'm going
to do it anyway to buy us time is really
bad they're actually hurting the small
landlords and what's the consequence
those people go bankrupt
who sweeps in the bigger companies and
then everybody's rent goes up so
congratulations there you go what do you
think jesse if you live on a squad
property contact me
i want to hear from you
is that you're building up the code is
your water not hot enough i need to know
these things so contact me on social
media and we'll maybe do something with
it there you love it
um i'm worried about these women they
seem confused that this wouldn't come
out publicly right maybe they don't care
maybe they just maybe they're maybe
they're corey bush and she's like i need
private security so i can take away your
security by getting rid of the police
it's the rule that the left get into
politics to exempt themselves from the
rules they enforce on others the gutfeld
rule there you go there you go and they
assume geraldo as dagon points out that
they would get a meet the media would
give them a pass we're the only people
talking about it
the media has given them a pass and does
give them a pass but i don't understand
how this is a scandal involving them
since they're landlords so they stand to
lose by the rent moratorium
done it themselves without pushing a law
are we sure they did not well they said
they collected 50 grand yeah so they
didn't cancel the rent for their own
tenants well that's bad
yeah it'd be hilarious if they were
relatives too and they still took their
money
that's what i would do but small
landlords are
i wanted one one day i'm going to be a
small landlord
i can dream can't be a tall one one more
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else